we have some startling exclusive images
tonight from the southern border take a
look at these images mass of illegal
immigrants thousands of them assembling
along one key entry point the numbers
are really staggering and according to
customs and border patrol the fact that
virtually none of them are vaccinated
and they are now setting up as you see
here a tent city under a bridge
is concerning to authorities there
correspondent bill malugen reports
tonight from del rio texas
my god look at that from a texas dps
helicopter fox news is getting an
exclusive look at the deteriorating
situation along the border here in del
rio texas and the footage is stunning
close to 11 thousand migrants all
crammed under the international bridge
waiting to be processed by a completely
overwhelmed border patrol some already
building makeshift shelters out of grass
and sticks others erecting tents a
majority of these migrants from haiti
which has a coveted vaccination rate of
under one percent from the air we
watched as a constant stream of hundreds
of people left mexico by crossing a dam
in the rio grande and then walked
illegally into the united states masses
of them gathering on the shore after
they cross from there we could see a
lengthy line of migrants walking a dirt
path towards the international bridge
where they will join the constantly
growing mass of people there nearby a
bulldozer clears a field apparently
making space for potential emergency
shelters or maybe a processing tent
sources on the ground sent us video
showing the situation from their
perspective as hundreds of migrants
cross illegally into the u.s without any
resistance on either side of the border
with more and weight on the mexican side
of the river and it happens all day long
the del rio mayor a democrat declaring a
local state of disaster as a result
there's people having babies down there
there's people collapsing out of the
heat it's something that it's very
challenging to describe in words but
it's extremely chaotic
and brett last night we learned that the
faa had suddenly issued a tfr a
temporary flight restriction in the area
around the bridge right here what that
meant was that our fox fox news drone
could no longer fly in the area and
bring everybody those images of the
migrants under the bridge at the time
the faa said it was for a special
security reason well i'm happy to give
an update today this morning fox news
filed a waiver with the faa to try to
get our drone back in the air happy to
report the faa cleared us this afternoon
we have been given clearance to fly our
drone once again here at the bridge we
will continue to do so in the coming
days we'll send it back to you bill
malugen live in del rio texas keep it up
thanks bill hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else